welcome back clark county credit union
the sponsors of this next segment has
some insights on the benefits of
monitoring your credit and tips on how
to get started
crystal welcome to las vegas now hi
thanks for having me oh absolutely we
always love to hear clark county credit
union's advice on financial health and
keeping us you know prepared and
knowledgeable about this topic so let's
start with why it's so important to you
know monitor your credit regularly let's
start there yeah
so credit monitoring is so important um
it's really important to know what's on
your credit especially if you're
planning on doing things like getting an
apartment getting a house getting a
credit card those things are reoccurring
in everybody's life so knowing what's on
your credit is so important to make sure
that there aren't any inaccuracies on
there
right inaccuracies but also we're
dealing with fraud out there as well
there's a there's a high rise of fraud
so what do we do in that sense
yeah they say that right now people
they've seen like about 20 of credit
reports having inaccurate information
and with those inaccuracies false
information it can really have a
negative impact on your credit report so
you want to make sure that you're
monitoring your credit and knowing
what's going on there so that you can
stop anything that shouldn't be on there
um before it turns into an issue for you
okay i know that can get really bad so
where should we start when it comes to
monitoring our credit what's step one
yeah
well step one is
viewing your credit report so there's a
couple ways that you can do it you can
either do like one of the free credit
reports from one of the national credit
bureaus um that's free another way is to
sign up with the credit monitoring
service a lot of times places will
charge like 20 per person to get those
started at the credit union county
credit union we offer our version of um
credit monitoring um as credit
monitoring service in addition to other
bonus services and deals and perks and
things like that our version is 5.95 and
it covers you in addition to your family
and your children which is also so
important
so what are some of the benefits that we
do receive with that credit monitoring
service yeah so you get full access to
your credit report at any time you want
to see it you'll also get monthly fraud
alerts to let you know if everything is
on track
a really cool thing is that it does
allow you to monitor the credit of your
children so a lot of people don't think
about monitoring your children's credit
but
in 2018 they did a child identity theft
report and they found out that over a
million children's identity had been
stolen and most of those children were
under seven years old so it's really
important to have that i know for me i
sign my kids up and it's really just a
kind of peace of mind to know that
something is monitoring and making sure
that they're safe so that in the future
they'll be ready to apply for those
things that life throws at them what
about bonus checking accounts
people can
get um sign up for an account online at
www.ccculv.org
once they sign up they'll be given
information to register for the identity
theft program and if they want to get
their children signed up all they need
is their social security number
of the children available for the online
registration if anybody has any
questions about it they can reach out to
one of our specialists at 702-228-2228
you